foreign
yeah dude you get those steel boners
that just controlled your life like a
compass due north I remember opening my
pants to pee and I would hear
about peeing out of a bone or just hot
peating sideways in a freaking thing
just a few pull your hand on the wall
and try to hold yourself up with one
hand to push your boner down with your
other hand yeah yeah like
like you're trying to force a drunk out
of a bar
[Laughter]
dude I remember like a person Jack and
late I remember they had this lady I'd
go outside in the morning so I'm in jerk
off outside and they had this lady that
would walk these two dogs right and so
the because I remember seeing on nature
Channel where if like their urine or
animal semen like some animals won't
it's like territory right so I remember
uh she'd walk these two dogs and I would
do it in like different spots to see if
the animal like what they would do like
a reaction
and uh the little one would go over
there and the big one would never even
really yeah it was like the little one I
guess almost felt like it was a cuck
yeah yeah
I want to go over the sniff your loads
but the big one didn't want that smoke
[Laughter]